[Musique]
comment j'allais
dans les années 1800
40 un jeune médecin du nom digne à ses
mails wass et des deux mers a accouché
le jour et disséquer décor décédé le
soir pour mieux comprendre l'anatomie
humaine et mieux venir en aide à ses
patients cependant il fut choqué de
constater que beaucoup de maires tombé
malade juste après l'accouchement de 10%
a parfois 20 % de ces mères décédèrent
après l'accouchement
et puis un jour c'est mal vice vie un
rapprochement entre les symptômes de ces
mères et ceux de ses collègues médecins
qui s'était légèrement coupée lors de la
dissection des cordes décédé se
pourrait-il que des substances invisible
entre alors en contact avec des parties
sensibles du corps humain les causes
ensuite les maladies qui frappent maire
et médecin
à partir de cet indice et de nombreux
autres dont parle notamment asklepios
dans cette superbe vidéo c'est mme
alleva s'introduisit une politique de
lavage de mains pour les médecins en
dans sa clinique de façon spectaculaire
le taux de décès des mères après
accouchement chute a à 2%
mieux encore quand en janvier 1848
semmelweis rondi le lavage de marc
obligatoire et plus strictes le taux de
décès chute à moins de 1%
incroyable en se lavant les mains on
pouvait sauver des vies ce mail va ce
n'était pas le premier à suggérer
l'importance de l'hygiène pour la santé
mais il y avait désormais des données
qui montrait de manière convaincante
l'efficacité de l'hygiène cependant en
connaître le traitement ne suffit pas à
sauver des vies
encore faut-il qu'ils soient administrés
et surtout respecter par les personnes
concernées en l'occurrence pour sauver
vraiment beaucoup de vies semmelweis
devait alors convaincre les autres
médecins de suivre les consignes
d'hygiène
malheureusement la communication de ces
mails weisz ne fut pas du tout à la
hauteur de son génie scientifique
semmelweis tarder a expliqué sa
découverte qui fut ainsi ré expliquer à
tort et à travers par d'autres et
obscurci par des théories douteuses de
particules de cadavres comme si la
substance morbide de ces cadavres se
transmettait aux mains des docteurs bien
sûr aujourd'hui on sait que c'est le cas
plus tôt on appelle ces particules des
germes qu'il s'agisse de bactéries ou de
virus
cependant à cette époque les idées des
formes et de ses mails weisz ne
paraissait vraiment pas scientifique
d'autant que pendant 13 ans semmelweis
lui-même refusa de publier ces
découvertes car il les trouvait évidente
l'arrogance de ce
mme weiss a sans doute beaucoup nui à sa
relation avec ses collègues
mais il ya pire alors que les autres
médecins lui demandait d'expliquer les
fondements scientifiques de sa théorie
semmelweis insulte à ses médecins en les
qualifiant de meurtrier
c'est me weiss aurait pu sauver des
milliers voire des millions de vies de
son vivant mais comme il n'a pas prêté
suffisamment attention à la
communication scientifique ces millions
d'individus ont succombé au manque
d'hygiène
le cadre de la pandémie actuelle est un
problème de communication finalement
similaire à celui de ses mails vice mais
à une échelle beaucoup beaucoup plus
grande
au lieu de changer le comportement d'une
poignée d'experts a priori bienveillant
il va nous falloir modifier radicalement
le comportement de milliards d'individus
sur terre parfois déjà septique des
autorités or les enjeux de ce changement
de comportement semble beaucoup plus
important que le cas de ces meules vice
encore faute d'une adoption adéquate des
gestes barrières de mesures d'hygiène
accrue et d'autres interventions plus
contraignantes comme lotto isolation
suite à une notification à l'exposition
au virus
il ya malheureusement fort à parier que
le déconfinement fasse passer la valeur
du taux de reproduction effectifs ou
dessus de 1
or comme on en a déjà parlé dans le
premier épisode de cette série
si ce taux de reproduction est supérieur
à 1 alors on subira à nouveau une
croissance exponentielle de la pandémie
qui conduira à une nouvelle surcharge
hospitalière qu'on ne pourra combattre
qu'à l'aide d'un second confinement
cette seconde vague à d'ailleurs déjà
frappé l'île d'hokkaido au japon qui a
finalement dû recourir à un second
confinement or un tel confinement
répéter ou prolongées fait encourir des
risques énormes à l'économie
de nombreuses entreprises pourraient
s'effondrer et entraîné dans leur chute
des millions d'emplois à l'échelle de la
france et des milliards à l'échelle
mondiale c'est en tout cas ce que
conclut ce rapport terrifiant de
l'organisation internationale du travail
qui suggère que la moitié de la main
d'oeuvre mondiale risque de perdre ses
moyens de subsistance
pire encore dans certains pays
développés le confinement s'est retrouvé
mêlé à des positionnements politiques
si bien que le débat sur le confinement
prend parfois des formes violentes aux
états unis en particulier des
manifestations armes et se sont même
organisés et ont menacé directement
certains gouverneurs d'état il semble
qu'il y a lieu de craindre que danser et
à la simple menace d'un second
confinement pourrait dégénérer dans un
pire scénario il semble que des guerres
civiles pourraient même être
envisageable surtout si une fraction de
la population ne dispose plus de quoi
subsister au quotidien sécuriser le
déconfinement semble donc critique et ça
pourrait être un enjeu d'ordre
planétaire des pays développés comme la
france ou la suisse semble avoir une
responsabilité non seulement envers
leurs populations défavorisées qui
risquent de terriblement souffrir d'un
chômage
structurelles ravageur mais aussi envers
des milliards de travailleurs de pays en
voie de développement qui souffrent de
la propagation du virus et de la chute
de l'offre et de la demande
l'appel à changer les comportements et
peut-être le traitement le plus efficace
dont nous disposons aujourd'hui pour
permettre un déconfinement sécurisé
cependant convaincre des milliards
d'individus dans le monde de modifier
leur comportement n'est absolument pas
une tâche aisée
il ne suffit pas de savoir ce que
d'autres devraient faire pour que
d'autres fassent ce qu'ils doivent faire
pour conduire à des changements de
comportement il est crucial de
développer toute une stratégie de
communication qui sera efficace pour
provoquer des changements de
comportements en particulier râler sur
twitter n'est sans doute pas une
stratégie particulièrement efficace tout
comme insultes et des collègues médecins
n'a pas été très efficace pour
semmelweis en fait selon le psychologue
de la santé choses là un road
les changements de comportements seront
beaucoup plus faciles à motiver si la
population comprend la nécessité de ces
changements de comportement or comme
l'illustrent le cas des contemporains de
ces mails wass l'efficacité de l'hygiène
n'a rien de si intuitif pire encore dans
notre cas il n'est vraiment pas évident
que se laver les mains en france
puissent aider à éviter des famines en
afrique ou que l'adoption massive des
applications de notification à
l'exposition à kovy 19 aujourd'hui
pourrait permettre de sauver des
millions de vies dans six mois pour
créer les modifications de comportement
recommandé par l'organisation mondiale
de la santé et par les épidémiologistes
les critiques de fournir à la population
des explications très pédagogique et
très convaincante de l'explication
scientifique de l'efficacité de ces
modifications de traitement or ce
contenu pédagogique ne sortira pas de
nulle part
il faut le créer malheureusement à
l'heure actuelle ce contenu pédagogique
est encore très déficient et la
production de ces contenus est encore
très mal financée mais l'existence de
contenus pédagogiques de qualité ne
suffit pas meyer infographie du monde
n'aura aucun effet si elle n'est pas vu
laisser la parole aux experts permet
certes de produire des contenus plus
fiables mais il n'est pas clair que ces
contenus seront plus pédagogique et
surtout n'est vraiment pas clair que ces
contenus seront suffisamment regardé en
termes d'impact il est en fait crucial
qu'il est là une collaboration plus
étroite entre des gros influenceurs
comme squeeze ou docteur usman et des
experts capables d'aider à la fiabilité
du texte sans toutefois dégradé la
qualité audiovisuelle et divertissante
de ses contenus bref bien communiquer ce
vraiment pas facile oui il faut produire
des contenus fiable et pédagogique
mais ces contenus doivent aussi être
intéressant et divertissant pour si
possible de venir viraux et à ce jeu là
à l'échelle mondiale et à propos de la
pandémie comme il dit 19
il y a un champion incontesté le vietnam
[Musique]
en particulier les autorités sanitaires
vietnamienne doute eu l'excellente idée
de collaborer avec des artistes pour
produire un contenu d'une qualités
pédagogiques et divertissantes
absolument exceptionnelle mieux encore
cette chanson a été reprise par des
influenceurs qui ont proposé une
chorégraphie qui illustre à merveille
comment se laver les mains efficacement
quelque chose que d'ailleurs
personnellement je ne savais absolument
pas faire avant le début de cette
pandémie
[Musique]
pourquoi
à
la vidéo originale qui a été publié sur
la chaîne de l'arc liste a maintenant 41
millions de vues sur youtube et sa
version chorégraphe et en a 5 millions
mais tout ça c'est juste deux vidéos sur
youtube
la chanson elle même a tellement été
diffusés à travers le monde et à travers
d'autres réseaux sociaux comme tictoc et
probablement snav s'arrêter instagram
que la chanson elle même a certainement
dépassé les 100 millions de vues depuis
la chanson a même été traduite en
anglais
[Musique]
il faut
mais aussi en thaïlandais et même en
chinois
[Musique]
on assiste à des spin-off japonais
même indien interprété par des policiers
[Musique]
moi
toi
[Musique]
incroyable vraiment incroyable vraiment
toutes mes félicitations aux autorités
vietnamiennes et d'ailleurs je ne sais
pas si cette communication fantastique
il y est pour beaucoup
mais le vietnam a complètement écrasé la
copie de 19 avec ce nom de cas au cours
des deux dernières semaines
le record du nombre de tests par
individu infecté ou monde est un zéro
pointé dans la statistique des morts par
kobe de 19
malheureusement en france rien qui
n'arrive à la cheville de cette
communication spectaculaire du vietnam
n'a été produit en tout cas à ma
connaissance en tout cas sur youtube les
vidéos les plus efficaces que j'ai
recensé à ce jour sont les suivantes le
23 mars des très gros influenceurs de la
youtube ce faire on produit une vidéo
collective avec un message très simple à
savoir restez chez vous cette vidéo a
sans doute eu un impact important ce que
bon pour commencer elle a fait 3
millions de vues qui plus est ce n'est
pas pareil d'entendre ce message venant
d'influenceurs qu'on suit au quotidien
par opposition à un scientifique inconnu
cependant le message est peut-être trop
simpliste pour être qualifié de
pédagogique et par ailleurs il est
peut-être survenue trop tard puisque la
vidéo a été publiée lors de la deuxième
semaine de confinement à ce jeu-là
squeeze a fait beaucoup beaucoup mieux
le 18 mars il a sorti une excellente
vidéo qui rentre bien plus en détail qui
appelle à rester chez soi et qui surtout
est sorti plus tôt
m6 est tout de même arrivé après le
début du confinement avec 4,7 millions
de vu cette vidéo est un peu mon coup de
coeur francophone dans un genre
similaire le rire jaune à lui sorti une
vidéo géniale le 20 mars qui appellent
très bien rester chez soi elle aussi
avec un angle aussi très pédagogique
avec 2,4 millions de vu j'ai envie de
dire merci et félicitations au rire
jaune
plus tôt dans la pandémie le 6 mars dr
norman a fait une vidéo très chouette
très pédagogique qui a atteint 1,7
million de vues il a enchaîné avec une
vidéo tout aussi chouette sur
l'efficacité du savon pour combattre le
coronavirus qui a atteint 500 milles vu
le 14 mars
il pensait lui a réalisé en live où il a
très bien expliqué la stratégie de
l'aplatissement de la courbe pour éviter
les surcharges hospitalière cette vidéo
a atteint 600 milles vue et puis comme
vous le savez sans doute plusieurs
vulgarisateur scientifique ou moi nous
nous sommes mobilisés pour produire le
même jour qu'une vidéo collective qui
comptait désormais un peu plus de 500
millions
les vidéos de dr nordmann d'y penser et
de ses vulgarisateurs scientifiques ont
peut-être eu un impact moindre que celle
des très gros influenceurs mais on peut
penser qu'ils ont un impact profond
parce qu'ils ont été davantage
pédagogique et on peut aussi penser que
le fait que de nombreux vulgarisateur se
soit mobilisée de cette manière a pu
aider d'autres personnes à relayer à
leur tour les recommandations de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé y
compris des plus gros influenceurs c'est
bien sûr spéculatifs mais je pense qu'on
peut voir la communication restreinte
des scientifiques comme étant
buts d'épidémie de communication
scientifique qui passe ensuite par des
médiateurs scientifiques avant de
possiblement atteindre des gros
influenceurs et le très grand public
en tout cas j'ai personnellement
consommé pas mal de contenu -
influenceurs freni disons comme les
vidéos du dr john campbell ou les
nombreuses publications et pré
publication scientifique que je cite
abondamment dans mes vidéos
j'espère personnellement que mes vidéos
pourront aider d'autres scientifiques à
mieux comprendre les enjeux critiques de
la crise actuelle et peut être motivée
des influenceurs beaucoup plus gros que
moi à relayer davantage ses
recommandations des organismes de santé
même si pour l'instant je dois bien
avouer que ça me semble pas être temps
le cas et que je suis resté un homme
probablement l'impact de mes vidéos
quoi qu'il en soit depuis le début de la
crise il y a eu énormément de contenu de
très grande qualité scientifique ou
philosophique dont l'impact me semble
très important même s'il est bien moins
direct que le contenu des très gros
influenceurs typiquement j'aimerais
citer les lives d'asclépios et de primum
no d'insérer et les vidéos de webdoc
dans ton corps ou encore la tronche en
biais mais la crise actuelle ne s'arrête
absolument pas à la médecine
thibault fiolet aborde l'épidémiologie
dirty biology les liens avec les
problèmes environnementaux
eureka est stupide économique les
aspects économiques au mot fabuleuse la
partie psychologie et monsieur fille et
maxime lambrecht la partie philosophie
en particulier philosophie morale
tandis que les vidéos de le monde et de
blanc qui aborde très bien beaucoup
d'aspects critiques pointent
déconfinement sécurisé enfin il y avait
ce monsieur bidouille et smart arrays
ont des vidéos très chouette sur ce que
des meilleurs peuvent faire pour aider
dans cette crise tous ses aspects
semblent critique pour gérer au mieux la
crise actuelle il me semble peut-être un
peu trop négligé à l'heure actuelle il
est crucial de les vulgariser comme
celle youtuber génialissime le font très
bien
cependant il me semble aussi que ces
vulgarisateur moi compris nous ne
faisons qu est gratinée la surface de
tout ce qu'il ya à comprendre la
recherche scientifiques avancent à un
rythme sans précédent et il va nous
falloir beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
des aides pour couvrir tout ce qu'il est
pertinent de comprendre dans la crise
actuelle pour motiver au mieux les
changements de comportements critiques
pour éviter un nouvel emballement
exponentielle de la pandémie
lors du décompte final d'autant que la
répétition aussi c'est important pour
qu'un changement de comportement soit
provoquée il semble critique que
beaucoup de gens venant de milieux très
différents
répète encore et encore le même
sage gardez vos distances physiques et
lavez vous les mains
ceci étant dit même s'il ya encore un
énorme manque de quantité de contenus de
qualité sur youtube à mon goût on y
trouvera sans doute est déjà largement
de quoi changer les comportements
quotidiens de la population
en plus des vidéos que j'ai déjà cité
côté francophone il ya énormément de
vidéos anglophone de très grande qualité
en particulier je me permet de
recommander cette excellente vidéo de
marc robert sur l'importance mais aussi
la difficulté de se laver les mains
suffisamment correctement pour enlever
toute trace du virus
le tout expliqué de manière absolument
limpide et divertissante
cette vidéo aurait certainement
convaincu les collègues de saint gilles
weiss même si bien sûr à utiliser des
connaissances modernes
ok mais comme on l'a vu cette vidéo
n'aura un impact que si elle fait
beaucoup de vue est alors oui les
youtuber ont clairement un rôle critique
à jouer en créant des vidéos de grandes
qualités pédagogiques et divertissantes
et en mettant des vignettes et des
titres pita clic et de l'autre côté les
viewer ou aussi un rôle à jouer en
cliquant davantage sur des vidéos
instructive et parlant de sujets
importants et en les partageant plutôt
que de cliquer et partager des vidéos
qui se contentent de râler à partir
d'informations douteuses ou peu fiables
mais de loin l'acteur le plus important
dans cette bataille de l'information est
certainement l'intermédiaire que celui
ci soit un média classique ou d'autres
cas une plateforme de réseau social
comme youtube et en particulier dans
notre cas l'algorithme de
recommandations de youtube un rôle clé à
jouer quelques chiffres youtube
c'est aujourd'hui presque 5 millions de
vues par minute soit plus que le nombre
de recherches sur google chaque jour ses
vues représente un milliard d'heures de
visionnage pour un total de 2 milliards
d'utilisateurs
ceci représente en moyenne 30 minutes
d'exposition à du contenu youtube pour 2
milliards d'utilisateurs par jour mais
surtout de vue sur trois sont le
résultat de recommandation par
l'algorithme de youtube ainsi deux fois
sur trois un utilisateur youtube ne
regarde pas ce qu'il a cherché où ce
qu'un ami lui conseille de regarder deux
fois sur trois l'utilisateur de youtube
oui vous vous regardez ce que youtube
vous recommande de regarder et ça ça a
un impact énorme si youtube veut
promouvoir une de mes vidéos
comme ce film culte à coup le cas il ya
quelques mois pour une vidéo arbitraire
de ma chaîne youtube peut le faire mais
malheureusement tant que l'algorithme de
youtube ne sera pas conçu pour être
robustement bénéfique
cet impact énorme de l'algorithme de
youtube ne sera pas clairement positif
voire il conduira à des effets
secondaires catastrophique
alors oui ça a un impact monumentale en
termes de mes informations comme
beaucoup l'on parle déjà et la
mésinformation n'est peut-être pas le
plus gros problème dans cette crise de
façon peut-être plus critique
l'information de qualité celle qui
pourra conduire à des changements de
comportement à grande échelle et à
anéantir la pandémie dévastatrice
actuelle pour ainsi sauver des millions
de vies et des milliards d'emplois sur
terre cette information de qualité si
critique au futur de l'humanité
elle se retrouve aujourd'hui noyée dans
un déluge de vidéos de moindre qualité
qui favorise davantage de sarcasme la
condescendance ou la virulence
aujourd'hui le plus critique n'est
peut-être pas de combattre des
informations idiote et dangereuse
plus critique semble peut-être d'inonder
youtube de contenus de qualité pour
maximiser la probabilité d'un tel
confinement
sécurisé et une fois que la crise sera
passée il me semble qu'il sera tout
aussi judicieux d'inonder youtube de
contenus de qualité sur d'autres sujets
comme le changement climatique la pensée
probabiliste ou le safety mode 7
mais bon c'est un pourra en débattre une
autre fois malheureusement à l'heure
actuelle les vidéo d'excellente qualité
font pour l'instant relativement peu de
vue par oui vous allez me dire cette
vidéo de marc robert a quand même 13
millions de vues oui mais ça ne semble
pas être temps grâce à l'algorithme de
youtube
cette excellente vidéo fait en fait
moins de vue que les autres vidéos de
marc robert on est par exemple très loin
des 40 3 millions de vues de sa vidéo
sur le dentifrice oeufs colorés ou des
79 millions de vues pour ces cadeaux
pour les voleurs de paquets de même la
vidéo de squeeze a fait moins de vue que
toutes les vidéos plus récentes qu'il a
fait ça je trouve ça terriblement
frustrant il contenu de grande qualité
informationnel ne sont pas mises en
avant par youtube voir ils sont noyés
dans un océan de vidéos de moindre
qualité informationnel on peut faire une
expérience pour bien s'en rendre compte
ouvrez un navigateur en mode privé et
charger la page d'accueil de youtube
puis compter les vidéos de qualité qui
parle des changements de comportements
nécessaires pour un déconfinement
sécurisé alors rien
rien depuis le début de la pandémie je
fais régulièrement cet exercice en
passant parfois par exemple par thor
pour ne pas avoir des recommandations
qui dépendent de ma localisation
géographique
rien à faire même quand il était urgent
de demander à la population de rester
chez soi très très très très peu sinon
aucune vidéo de qualité liée à la coved
19 n'était recommandé noter qu'il ne
s'agit absolument pas de mettre que des
vidéos de sciences dans cette page
d'accueil mais juste mettre une vidéo de
temps à autre dans cette liste qui
suggère que la pandémie doit être prise
au sérieux que rester chez soi peut
sauver des vies et que bien se laver les
mains n'est pas si facile
une vidéo par exemple toutes les cinq
recommandations ça ne me paraît pas si
contraignant et pourtant ça pourrait
suffire à nodier des milliards
d'individus vers de meilleures habitudes
pour combattre la pandémie actuelle
d'autant que simple exposition à
l'information a un effet vraiment
important surtout si cette exposition
est répétée dans cette excellente vidéo
veritas yom présente par exemple une
expérience où des étudiants sont
exposées de manière répétée innocente et
presque inconsciente à des mots qui
n'ont aucun sens comme cardigan après
une expérience contrôler les chercheurs
ont découvert que les mots que les
étudiants voyait plus souvent été jugée
plus positif par ses étudiants
ça peut paraître très décevant pour la
nature humaine et pour l'ego de notre
espèce mais oui l'exposition répétée
ça marche ça modifie les comportements
les croyances et les émotions
dans une autre étude impressionnante des
chercheurs de princeton et de facebook
montré que le simple fait de retirer
seulement 10% des postes négatif sur
facebook ce qui est vraiment une
intervention un film ça suffit à
augmenter le taux de postes positif
écrit par les utilisateurs exposés à
cette modification de l'algorithme et ce
après seulement une semaine
sachant tout ce que l'on sait de la
psychologie humaine et je vous renvoie
vers cette excellente vidéo domo fabius
pour en savoir plus il semble que rendre
l'algorithme de youtube robustement
bénéfique serait probablement l'une des
interventions les plus efficaces pour
combattre au mieux la pandémie actuelle
et réduire significativement les risques
de seconde vague
d'autant qu'une telle intervention sur
l'algorithme ne modifierait pas
uniquement le comportement des
spectateurs comme l'expliquent très bien
veritas y sommes dans cette autre vidéo
l'algorithme influence aussi et surtout
les youtuber ne pas augmenter leur vue
lorsqu'ils font un boulot énorme pour
parler d'un sujet aussi difficile à
vulgariser que la crise actuelle c'est
aussi les décourager fortement
consciemment ou non à davantage traitée
et à s'intéresser à ce sujet
malheureusement de la vie de veritas
yonne il me semble aussi que d'ortie
baloji en a parlé en tout cas je peut
l'attester largement pour mon cas
personnel le nombre de vues des vidéos
scientifique diminue
oui vous avez bien entendu il diminue
malgré tous les discours de youtube sur
la promotion de la science et le combat
contre les faits que news la science est
de plus en plus martyrisé par cette
plateforme ou du moins les contenus de
grande qualité pédagogique ne font pas
autant de vue que ce qu'on pourrait
espérer en particulier je suis frustré
de voir que cette vidéo de marc robert
n'a que 13 millions de vues il me semble
qu'il est devenu urgent pour que ce
genre de vidéos face des centaines de
millions de vues et de même j'ai supplié
les gens à youtube en privé et je les
supplie maintenant publiquement de faire
en sorte que des vidéos comme la vidéo
collective des vulgarisateurs
scientifiques de youtube surtout dans le
contexte tel qu'il était à ce moment là
face 10 millions de vues au lieu de cinq
cent mille de ces contenus pourra être
le meilleur traitement dont nous
disposons actuellement pour des cons
fine et de manière sécurisée
malheureusement youtube de l'administrer
pas
alors il ya comme une bonne raison à
cela malheureusement quand on parle
longuement dans notre livre le fab le
chantier concevoir un algorithme de
recommandations robustement bénéfique
est une tâche extrêmement complexe
surtout avec les technologies
d'intelligence artificielle limitée
d'aujourd'hui d'alors on pourrait
vouloir se tourner vers des
recommandations humaines des vidéos de
qualité sur le coup vite 19
malheureusement cette tâche est aussi
très probablement hors de portée des
humains aussi en effet identifié les
vidéos les plus robustes mais bénéfique
est difficile pour un humain pour
plusieurs raisons la première est que
simplement reconnaître si une
information et fiable demande beaucoup
de travail et d expertise surtout en
période de crise où tant de données peu
fiable circulent et tant
d'interprétations trompeuses sont
proposées à titre personnel en tout cas
beaucoup d'aspects que j'aborde en ce
moment dans mes vidéos correspondent à
la limite de ma compréhension des choses
qui est elle même extrêmement aisée j'ai
été moi même contraints de m'appuyer sur
des données peu fiable et de proposer
des interprétations biaisées
même si j'espère que ma présentation de
mode incertitudes sur ses
interprétations et les relectures de mes
scripts par de nombreux scientifiques
rendent mes discours suffisamment
robuste le mans bénéfique
pire encore la crise a atteint un niveau
d'interdisciplinarité tels que personne
ne maîtrise tous les aspects de cette
crise un médecin aura ainsi beaucoup de
mal à juger de la qualité des vidéos
d'oreca tout comme un épidémiologiste
non informaticiens galère aura sans
doute à comprendre si une vidéo sur une
technologie de notification à
l'exposition présente bien les risques
ou non on fait même un informaticien
aurait du mal vu que l'impact de cette
technologie dépend de la manière dont
les humains l'utiliseront ce qui
nécessitera des notions de sciences
humaines et sociales
bref identifier les contenus de qualité
c'est compliqué
malheureusement très peu de moyens
financiers algorithmique et humains sont
assignés à l'identification des contenus
de qualité et à leur mise en avant mais
la difficulté à reconnaître les contenus
de qualité n'est pas la seule limitation
des humains il y a aussi le problème de
sélectionner les vidéos a analysé dans
l'immensité des contenus youtube
il ya par exemple énormément de vidéos
qui sont potentiellement très chouette
comme les vidéos du cnrs par exemple
mais que je n'ai pas eu le temps de
vision
et moi même pour surveiller toute la
communication scientifique sur youtube
et identifier le meilleur de tout cela
surtout en temps réel il va falloir des
armes et d'experts en sciences et en
communication scientifique mais surtout
il ya un travail de personnalisation des
recommandations énorme à effectuer pour
comprendre la propagation des pandémies
les vidéos de fribourg en bois sont
certainement ce qu'il ya de mieux a
recommandé mais à des scientifiques et à
des mathématiciens
cependant ces mêmes vidéos ne sont
probablement pas ce qu'il ya de plus
pertinent a recommandé par exemple pour
un individu dont les parents sont
infectés par acofi de dix neuf ou pour
un enseignant qui s'apprête à reprendre
le chemin des classes
en fait à l'heure actuelle il semble
qu'une combinaison des meilleurs
algorithmes et des meilleures
compétences humaines en sciences en
mathématiques et en philosophie soit
devenu indispensable pour espérer
concevoir des recommandations efficace
pour ensuite générer des changements de
comportements capable de garantir un
déconfinement sécurisé idéalement cet
exercice critique de recommandations de
contenus de qualité devrait sans doute
être une collaboration inédite entre des
plateformes influentes comme du tube et
des entités de confiance et de haut
niveau d'expertisé comme l'organisation
mondiale de la santé des agences
sanitaires nationales et des instituts
de recherche
à titre personnel c'est d'ailleurs
quelque chose sur laquelle j'aimerai
davantage travailler dans les mois à
venir
donc si vous travaillez pour l'une de
ces structures et si vous pensez pouvoir
aider à aller dans ce sens je vous
invite à me contacter pour voir ce qu'on
peut mettre en place
aujourd'hui on a vu que connaître les
traitements efficaces ne suffisait pas
surtout quand c'est traitement nécessite
des changements de comportement de la
population pour que ces traitements soit
effectif il semble en particulier
indispensable qu'il soit accompagné
d'une communication scientifique de très
grande qualité à la fois fiable et
pédagogique mais aussi intéressante
divertissante et si possible virale mais
ce n'est pas tout un contenu de grande
qualité n'aura aucun effet s'il n'est
pas consommée or pour qu'il soit
consommé il est crucial aujourd'hui
qu'ils soient mises en avant
soit par les médias classiques soit par
les réseaux sociaux ceci dépend des
créateurs oui mais ça dépend aussi du
public mais aussi et surtout ça dépend
énormément de la sélection effectuée par
les médias classiques ou par les
algorithmes de recommandation
malheureusement concevoir des
algorithmes de recommandations
robustement bénéfique est une tâche
monumentale que ce soit pour les humains
ou pour les algorithmes
il semble qu'une collaboration entre les
deux soit indispensable pour y arriver
malheureusement pour l'instant les
moyens financiers algorithmique et
humains alloués à l'identification de la
recommandation de contenu de très grande
qualité informationnel sont cliniquement
faible prendre les recommandations
robustement bénéfique est un fabuleux
chantier qui me semble malheureusement
gravement négligé jusque là si vous
voulez y contribuer et si vous pouvez y
contribuer je vous supplie de le faire
on parle beaucoup dans notre livre de
comment contribuer mais la première
étape est simplement de sensibiliser
davantage de gens à l'opportunité à côté
de laquelle on est en train de passer en
négligeant beaucoup trop la tâche de la
recommandation de contenus de qualité
une seconde chose à faire est de
promouvoir un raisonnement plus justes
notamment plus probabiliste en faisant
preuve d'un maximum de pédagogie et de
bienveillance dans la guerre contre
qu'ovide 19 la bataille de l'information
sera une bataille critique à gagner
enfin une troisième chose qui peut être
fait est de systématiquement cherché à
partager des contenus de qualité
le travail de modération et de
recommandations c'est aussi vous qui le
faites donc plutôt que de partager un
contenu peu fiables ou de partage et de
la stupidité pour vous en moquez vous
pourriez sans doute davantage réduire
les risques de catastrophes sanitaires
et économiques en promouvant
systématiquement uniquement des contenus
de grandes qualités à commencer peut
être par cette excellente vidéo de
marque rubber cette fascinante réflexion
domo fabulous où cette incroyable
chansons des autorités sanitaires
[Musique]
et oui quand
je crois
[Musique]
j'ai levé le camp
à
[Musique]